exposing and defunding America's killing
machine that's the focus of tonight's
angle in 2016
Planned Parenthood performed one-third
of all abortions in the United States
the number a staggering 320 1384 unborn
children despite laws prohibiting the
federal funding of abortion Planned
Parenthood received more than half a
billion dollars in government grants and
reimbursements last year
well since the money is fungible it can
be used then for facilities staff and
activities that support abortion
services
now you're gonna remember during the
campaign when the president repeatedly
vowed to defund Planned Parenthood
unless they stop with the abortions we
don't do the funding for the stuff that
we want because I'm totally against the
abortion aspect of Planned Parenthood
I wouldn't fund it if they have the
abortion going on and it's been a big
factor Planned Parenthood should
absolutely be defunded I mean if you
look at what's going on with that it's
terrible stripping Planned Parenthood of
its federal dollars is kind of tricky
because four hundred and forty million
dollars of its funding comes through
Medicaid President Trump has already
signed a bill rescinding the Obama era
regulations that mandated that states
fund Planned Parenthood through their
Medicaid budgets that was good but what
about the remaining sixty million
dollars that Planned Parenthood receives
from you the taxpayers well that comes
from something called title ten funding
federal grants dedicated to family
planning education counseling health
screening etc now the president has on
his desk new title ten rules that will
deny Planned Parenthood funding and
these regulations stipulate that at that
no organization performing abortions
would qualify for title ten grants
depriving Planned Parenthood thus of
tens of millions of dollars now the
president is apparently weighing whether
to greenlight the new rules or not soon
retired president of Planned Parenthood
Cecile Richards is claiming Trump and
other politicians are targeting not
abortion but something else
unfortunately at the state level more
and more I think it depends on the
legislature but they're taking political
aim at women's health women's access to
basic health care this is of course
total bunk abortion is not health care
certainly not to the baby it destroys
and the other main services that Planned
Parenthood provides our STD tests HIV
tests pregnancy tests and contraception
Oh in contrary to what the abortion
giant often says well they don't offer
mammograms no so here's the reality of
their services and these are Planned
Parenthood's own figures abortions
outnumbered prenatal services 41 to one
in 2016 for every eighty three abortions
they provided one adoption referral one
the organization performed about 200
percent more cancer screenings back in
2006 then last year in 2017 so it's
going the other way for cancer
screenings and of the 2.4 million
clients they saw last year Planned
Parenthood only offered about 32,000
Family Practice services okay out of 2.4
million let's be brutally honest here
abortion is Planned Parenthood's
stock and trade it's their only
specialty and it's their cash cow and by
funding them the federal government is
depriving the 13,000 qualified actual
health care centers their money that
they would otherwise offer more women
services than you know then the Planned
Parenthood IUD in a quickie abortion so
those other great clinics they're out of
luck Trump was terrific and exposing
this abortion racket in the Democrats
obsession with it it did it in the last
presidential debate
I loved this moment
donal des said he's in favor of
defunding Planned Parenthood even
supported shutting the government down
to defund Planned Parenthood I will
defend Planned Parenthood I will defend
roe v wade and I will defend women's
rights to make their own healthcare
decisions mr. Trump your reaction and
particularly on this issue of late term
partial birth well I think it's terrible
if you go with what Hillary is saying in
the ninth month you can take the baby
and rip the baby out of the womb of the
mother just prior to the birth of the
baby now you can say that that's okay
and Hillary can say that that's okay but
it's not okay with me Monica Crowley and
I were in the Fox trailer watching the
debate at that moment and I looked I
said he just won the election that was
one of the best moments for Donald Trump
period it's awesome well for the
president these new title ten
regulations are an opportunity to
fulfill a campaign promise to complete
what he started
by rolling back the Obama Medicaid regs
and also a chance to give real health
care providers a shot at federal funding
in fact that Congress fully funded
Planned Parenthood in the omnibus bill
was and is a complete outrage I my blood
is still boiling about that but by
restricting title 10 funds from print
Planned Parenthood the president can
satisfy his pro-life base millions of
evangelicals Catholics mothers and
fathers while giving them a reason to
rally before the midterms but most
importantly signing these new title 10
regulations may save the lives of women
and their precious children and that's
the angle